في بعض الأيام ، كان الكون يريدك فقط أن
تعمل ، ولن يكون من الرائع أن
تقترح حسنًا في المستقبل ، سيكون
لديك بالتأكيد نسخة مصطنعة من
نفسك تذهب إلى هناك وأؤديها
بتكاليف لا تريد فعلها حقًا
هذا يبدو جيدًا جدًا بحيث لا يمكن
تصديقه مثل الصورة الرمزية أو شيء أراه
هو التقني الذي يقف وراء الصورة الرمزية
ومجموعة كاملة من الأفلام المختلفة
والآن يستخدم سحر هوليوود هذا
لتغيير معنى العمل ، أنا رائع
أنا هنا للمساعدة في مقابلة Korra
إنها نسخة رقمية من
جوقة بشرية فعلية متسقة Cora Cora Never
Sleeps Cora قادرة على الإجابة على الأسئلة على
مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع ،
إنها بخير إنها رائعة جدًا ، لماذا لا
تقوم بتوظيفها في بعض النقاط في عام 2018.
يجري حاليًا اختباره
كمندوب خدمة عملاء وأحد
أكبر البنوك في بريطانيا العظمى ، لقد فقدت سيارتي ، وكان
هناك وكلاء افتراضيون آخرون
لدي في قاعدتنا ، لكنني لم
أر أي شيء واقعي تمامًا مثل
Cora  مثل روبوت الدردشة
ولكنه يحلل تعابير وجهك
وكلامك وقد تم تطويره هنا في
شركة ذكاء اصطناعي مقرها نيوزيلندا
تسمى Sol
machine ، الهدف الأساسي منه هو جعل
الآلات أكثر شبهاً بنا
لفهم التقاطع بين
علوم الكمبيوتر  والوعي البشري ،
باعت آلات Sol عددًا قليلاً من
الصور الرمزية لشركات في جميع أنحاء العالم
مرحبًا بك في صناديق Miss Sadie
ويبدو مألوفًا بشكل صحيح ،
لذا فمع دخول هذه الصور الرمزية إلى القوى العاملة ،
فهذا يعني أننا كبشر سيتم
استبدال ما يتم استبداله بالفعل
هو الإنسان  القدرة على القيام بالأشياء
بسرعة وبشكل متكرر وهذا
نوع من الارتياح لأن
مئات الملايين من العمال في جميع أنحاء العالم قد
يفقدون وظائفهم في العقود القادمة
وهو أمر مخيف ولكن أيضًا فرصة
لمقاربة العمل بشكل مختلف ربما في
غضون 10 سنوات وربما في غضون 20 عامًا.  بحاجة إلى
النظر في كيفية تعريفنا للعمل ،
وهذا نوع من السؤال الأكبر الذي
نحتاج إلى الإجابة عليه بصفتنا مجتمعًا  بعد كل شيء ،
ترى الآلة عالماً حيث
لدينا توأم رقمي في المستقبل ، نعتقد تمامًا
أنه سيكون هناك الملايين إن
لم يكن المليارات من البشر الاصطناعيين
الموجودين ، وإذا كان بإمكانك إرسال نفسك المزيفة
إلى المكتب كل يوم ، فكيف
تريد  اختر قضاء وقتك